and what the problem is
um now we women think that they have to
give up nothing and can still be married
you know because even your dancing stuff
I'm sure if if I was if I was um a guy
like your brother was dating a girl and
if there was like provocative dancing
like you probably he probably wouldn't
want that yeah no he definitely wouldn't
want that but then obviously you have to
explain to them this is what I have to
do in my career right but they have to
accept it in a way no they don't but
this is the thing it depends what's
important yeah so some people career is
more important than family yeah some
people family is more important than
career yeah and so you know it just kind
of shows what you value yeah it does
yeah you know and it's not not no not
bad thing well it's a bad thing for
families yeah it's not a bit doesn't
mean you're a bad person and so a lot of
times like when I talk I think people
think I'm talking about you not you but
like yeah yeah in general people think
I'm talking about a personal thing but